nathan is in grand rapids hi nathan how
are you
great dave hi anthony thank you guys for
taking my call
sure i'm a 22 year old master
student and i currently have about 30
thousand dollars
from my undergraduate degree okay you're
fine what your phone came out you have
how much in student loan debt
about thirty thousand thirty thousand
dollars all right yes
um i was very fortunate that i received
a trust fund from my for my grandparents
when i was in high school
that i'll soon be able to access um at
the time it was worth about 33 000
and it has since grown to about 58 000
my question is whether i should use the
money in that trust fund to immediately
pay off
all of my student loan debt or if i
should
work and pay that student loan debt out
of
future wages and then have that trust
fund continue to accumulate
and use that as a down payment on a
house when do you graduate
uh hopefully as long as things go well
this coming spring so spring of 2022.
how are you paying for the following
this coming year
um so i received a graduate
assistantship which covers all of the
funds for all the costs for college and
then i get a small stipend as well
so i don't have to pay for my my
graduate degree and what are you living
on
uh i'm living mostly on that graduate
stipend which is about 12 000 a year
right now
and then i have a couple side gigs as
well okay so you're not
um going into further debt
correct that's good okay i'd pay off
student loan debt today then
absolutely now do you have any other
debt though nathan
any credit card from student loans okay
so no credit cards no no car notes
no absolutely i'll go ahead and cut that
check today
yeah i'll just be debt-free and then
that that still leaves you
with um 20 something thousand dollars
laying around in that trust fund that
you can use to start your life with
after graduation
yeah uh you use some of that for your
emergency fund and maybe some of that
for about maybe some of what's
left over above that for your down
payment on your first house absolutely
no rush on the house you're doing great
now dave let me ask you a question i'm
pretty sure america's thinking well why
not dave
let let the other 20 thousand sit in the
trust and let it grow it could
from now until graduation but at that
point i would move it to
an emergency fund and to a down payment
fund yes sir and uh
so it's invested is what it amounts to
you can leave it there yeah but
i pay off student loan today absolutely
out of it and be just be clear
and and make sure then that you have a
plan for no additional debt
yes and it sounds like you got a plan
for that sounds like you gotta you know
we
question you through that we walk
through it so it sounds like you've got
a
a way to pull that off and just make
sure you stick to that plan
yeah whatever it takes in america the
reason why dave acts
hey how you can get through the rest
because then we would have said hey
take that money and cash flow the rest
of your college experience
then when you graduate take the rest of
it to pay off your student loans
and then go into baby steps 3 and 3b
because goal number one
is no more debt yes you can't there's no
sense in with the left hand paying off
debt with the right hand going back in
it right
that that's just you're just dog chasing
his tail at that point it's not you're
not making
any progress so it's exactly right yeah
that's the plan
and anthony he he's done a really really
smart thing there he's
become an employee yes in a sense of the
of the school and that sets him up to be
a
uh doing graduate work for free for free
and when you look at it i mean i talk
about this in my book dave is
figure out how can you work for the
school to get a paycheck
um or to get your tuition reduced or
free you know and sometimes some schools
dave now are doing we'll give you
a a small paycheck like he said twelve
thousand dollars a year and your tuition
for free
that's a great program to go into but
here's the thing today if people are not
stepping back and doing their research
to see what's out there and by the way
all the jobs
at colleges that are universities that
you can do
that would allow you to go there
debt-free because you're an employee
don't have to be glamorous right you can
be the janitor
yes sir yes you can be the janitor and
for four years
absolutely and go to school for free and
sweep floors
or bus tables or whatever yeah i mean
you can be the
the you know the guy working out there
driving the lawn tractor right
doesn't matter with a weed eater i don't
care what you're doing
um and so it doesn't have to be like you
you got some kind of uh
white-collar high-tech job or something
at the university
i just want you to be on their payroll
so you get the employee benefit of
free tuition that's it doesn't have to
look good that's part of the debt-free
degree plan yeah my philosophy is it
doesn't have to look good to be good
this is the ramsey show